rallycross in my project cars it's more  likely than you think  Slightly Mad Studios is gearing up the  sequel to its well-received racing  simulator with more than just a host of  minor tweaks and improvements project  cars too will now feature rallycross  competitions with cars to match so  expect to hone your drifting skills it's  a welcome addition to the sequel  especially for a series looking to keep  up with the Gran Turismo sand forces of  the world  slightly mad provided us with these  scenes to give you an idea of the fierce  competition you'll face on the tarmac we  expect more project cars to footage in  the future so give us a thumbs up and  subscribe to our channel if you're  interested to see more if you have  strong opinions about rally racing or  project cars - in general let us know in  the discussion below thanks for watching  [Applause]  No  [Music]  you